pet ensuite on va aller sur d'autres
activation et l'or c'est important
qu'est ce que c'est que cette activation
c'est en fait quelque chose qui permet
de dire que le cerveau est quand même
variable en fonction du contexte
bah oui la perception douloureuse va
être variable en fonction du contexte et
pas uniquement du stimulus ça peut être
indépendant de l'aide de l'intensité du
stimulus vous pouvez être très fortement
active et dans le cerveau mais c'est pas
dépendante baptiste d'intensité du
stimulus physique
en même temps ça va arriver oui voilà
c'est une influence descendante à
différents étages donc ces modules et le
ghana sources et surtout regarder cette
matrice vous la mettez en jeu et vous la
moduler quand vous êtes distrait vous
allez réduire l'activation de la matrice
primaires parce que cette matrice va
induire à ce moment là un rétro contrôle
c'est la façon la distraction marche
vous avez tous essayé de distraire le
dit serait un gamin qui a une douleur et
enfin vous pouvez focaliser à la mer ce
et l'avouent majorer la matrice
primaires c'est cette matrice secondaire
qui fait ça donc si vous êtes motivés
pour vous focalisez vous aurez plus mal
il ya aucun problème
voilà donc une dernière type dernier
type d'activation encore plus tard c'est
différent cortex différentes zones
cérébrales un peu compliqué je rentre
pas dans le détail
mais celle ci est importante c'est celle
ci qui fait voter pas mal d'abrutis
trump mais c'est aussi celle ci qui vous
permet d'aimer d'aimer votre compagne
votre conjoint vos enfants etc
c'est celle qui vous permet d'avoir le
libre arbitre et la décision elle fait
pas que ça mais voilà et à la signent
elle assigne cette zone des valeurs ou
choses hein et elle fait des
comparaisons c'est pas si simple que ça
mais c'est un peu grossier mais voilà
alors que se passe-t-il bassesse à la
matrice tertiaire c'est la dernière
elle évalue et elle donne cette fois une
valence émotionnelle aux choses elle est
très tardive mais elle explique l'effet
placebo les croyances et c'est très
important
elle va moduler la matrice secondaires
donc c'est un empilement c'est d'abord
une pelure d'oignon et ensuite c'est une
descente comme sa progressive en
empilement voilà alors sachez qu'elle
est très consciente
c'est l'accès à la mémorisation c'est là
qu'on va mémoriser et elle est activée
en à peu près 500 à 1000 millisecondes
en une seconde
c'est ça l'expérience douloureuse une
stimulation induit tout ça
tout ça à la fois en une seconde ça se
construit donc voilà c'est important
pour activer cette matrice sans aucune
stimulation de cissé petit elle est poli
modal c'est à dire qu'elle peut être
active à part d'autres stimulus est
exactement et surtout regarder on peut
la modifier dans des conditions diverses
quand on est en attente orienté c'est
l'effet nocebo au placebo quand on a des
représentations des croyances on croit
en dieu on modifie différemment s'ils
ont pris pendant l'expérience
douloureuse c'est est démontré il ya
cinq ans ça également ça dépend des
capacités de confiance en soi etc et
enfin c'est important lorsque vous êtes
un médiateur zen
attention la méditation zen c'est
quelque chose d'assez clair précis c'est
pas simple quand vous avez 1000 heures
de méditation
en fait c'est entre 1000 et 10 mille
mais les vraies mais dictateur zen ils
ont dix mille heures de méditation lee
miller des dizaines d'habitations ses
quinze à vingt ans d'expérience d'accord
ils sont capables de modifier cette
matrice tertiaire qui est extrêmement
élaboré et vous pouvez activer sa dans
un certain nombre de cas que je vais
vous montrer mes et vous allez changer
votre souffrance en hédonisme alors
comment fait-on c'est pas très compliqué
d'abord je voulais vous montrer que si
vous anticipez votre l'arrivée de la
douleur vous prenez quelqu'un qui a mal
parce qu'on lui a stimulé par exemple
aux premières espace un terreau 2 sur
dur salle vous le mettez sous la machine
puis vous dites voilà vous avez eu mal
pendant la simulation
maintenant on va recommencer dans 5 4 3
2 une seconde voilà vous allez et donc
on dit aux gens attention un 5 4 3 et au
lieu de mettre en route la machine au
moment où on stimule on met la machine
en route juste avant d'en cas pas de
stimulation et qu'est ce que vous voyez
ce moment là mais a oublié que dans le
cerveau alors je me suis trompé parce
que c'est la diapo d'après donc on va
aller plus vite
et puis les copains ils vont me faire un
un petit truc que voilà donc voilà c'est
ça il se passe ça vous allez retrouver d
activation dans la zone de l'ags
réhabiliter et vous allez trouver d
activation dans la zone de las alliance
mais aucune activation de la matrice
primaire dans la zone perceptive c'est à
dire vous êtes déjà en train de préparer
quand vous avez peur d'avoir mal
vous préparez votre cerveau à construire
la matrice de la douleur la matrice
primaire celle qui stimule est vraiment
immédiatement par une vraie stimulation
quand même pas mal ça vous préparer à
avoir mal quand vous avez la trouille
d'avoir mal mais alors vraiment
biologiquement
il n'y a pas de souci voilà donc on va
revenir sur tout à l'heure ici c'est
l'effet placebo effet placebo c'est
quelque chose qui permet d'avoir des
effets antalgiques chez un certain
nombre de personnes et alors il dépend
de quoi les placebos répondeur ils ont
une forte activation 1 du lobe frontal
de ce qui vous fait humain et puis il
est passé votre répondeur les gens qui
n'y croit pas trop et c'est pas très
active alors ça c'est très important
parce que en fait on est tous des
placebos répondeur mais plus ou moins et
donc ça dépend de la personnalité ça et
ça dépend aussi du contexte
voilà le contexte et la personnalité
extrêmement modifié dans ce cadre voilà
alors on va terminer par des choses
sympathiques
du moins je l'espère voilà on va passer
les diapos il doit manquer de piles de
coco la voilà donc quand vous regardez
quinquin souffrir par exemple cette
personne qui est en bas qui ont fait
subir quelque chose je crois que c'était
avant tout un hameau ça c'est un truc
ouais sous sous sous bush voilà donc on
regarde le cerveau des gens qui
regardent l'autre souffrir oui je suis
traître je suis pas anti américains mais
ils nous ont quand même bien enfin il
nous envoie la wii vous avez tous
compris c'est bien et donc qu'est ce que
vous voyez vous voyez à nouveau que
certaines zones sont activés comme
exactement comme les zones de tout à
l'heure d'anticipation là on est dans
l'empathie c'est pareil on a le zone de
l'ags réhabiliter ou la désagréable
itella c'est la désagréable tu es qui
s'activent et pour la zone donc de l'as
alliance du stimulus
on est là sur les bases de l'empathie
vraiment sur les bases de l'empathie et
ça se fait automatiquement chez tout le
monde
donc vous ne souffrez pas mais vous
comprenez bien la souffrance de l'autre
parce que vous n'êtes pas loin d'une
activation cérébrale qui est celle de la
perception douloureuse et en plus de la
matrice primaire alors nous les
professionnels de santé on est des
pourquoi parce que quand on
regarde ça et qu'on demande à quelqu'un
dans la rue de juger du niveau de
douleur perçue par la personne pour
laquelle on a fait le film regarder ce
que font les les contrôles c'est à dire
les gens dans la rue ils disent oulala
il souffre beaucoup au moins 7 sur 10 0
je ne souffre pas dix sur dix est
horrible ou intolérable où inimaginable
et puis la désagréable ilité hoyé pays
une plaisante naissent à d et gravité
pareil et quand vous demandez à des
experts les experts c'est l'assistante
sociale de l'hôpital
c'est l'infirmière c'est le directeur de
l'hôpital c'est le médecin un oui ils
sont cote
nous souhaitons en permanence à la
différence de celui qui n'est pas un
expert entre guillemets sanitaires ou en
tout cas de la santé et d'où ça vient ça
va ça vient de ça ça vient que de façon
inconsciente
notre cerveau tiens tiens tiens comme
c'est rigolo dans le lobe préfrontal
décide de résister et on souccot la
valeur de l'autre même si on devrait
nous l'assurent côté puisqu'on devrait
être en pleine d'empathie
on est des professionnels de santé c'est
une protection mais c'est aussi un choix
est ce à ce module et vous voyez qu'il
ya quelques différences dans la zone de
l'ags réhabilité ici je vais terminer
parce que ça peut être très très long
mais par des choses sympathiques
soulagement quand vous êtes soulagé
d'une douleur vous avez une douleur
aiguë vous prenez un médicament ou bien
vous faites quelque chose qui vous
soulage d'une douleur au moment où vous
sentez que la douleur disparaît vous
sentez un sentiment de plaisir
il ya une espèce de sensations de
plaisir le soulagement c'est exactement
comme une récompense ou presque en tout
cas il ya des grandes similitudes et
regarder s'activent des zones bien
particulière que mon collègue connais
qui sont les zones ici qu'on appelle le
teg mentale ventrale c'est les zones
entre guillemets impliqués dans le
système de la récompense et du plaisir
voilà un essai pareil lorsque vous avez
des récompenses alimentaire on pourrait
trouver ça chez les animaux c'est
intéressant je suis soulagé c'est comme
si vous stimuler le système de la
récompense avec un sentiment d'agréer
habilité très marquée et alors je
voulais vous montrer quelque chose pour
finir comment ils font ces gens là
comment ils font bon ils le font
volontairement il respondi comme ça
plusieurs heures est-ce qu'ils ont mal
bas et probablement pas parce que s'ils
le font c'est qu'ils ont du plaisir donc
ils ont été capables de faire un truc
dingue
ils ont basculé par leur activation
cérébrale des zones 1 qui leur
permettent ici
ils comprennent bien le stimulus
alliance du stimulus mais il assigne une
valeur à ce stimulus et cette valeur
fait qu' ils activent le système de la
récompense pas mal quand même
donc on fait ce qu'on veut et que sa
tête a franchement on a beau merdier au
niveau du corps en fait ce qu'on veut et
donc ça permet à la
c'est vrai qu'on voit pas en bas ça
permet de comprendre beaucoup de choses
notamment le sadomasochisme et c'est
donc tout stimulus port corporel peut
être ressenti de façon plaisante même un
stimulus no6 sceptiques qui devrait
donner une douleur alors très rapidement
ici vous avez un cerveau qui est en mode
par défaut contrôle c'est quoi le mode
par défaut je suis allongé je fais rien
je ferme les yeux
j'entends rien je ne sens rien je suis
en suspension
le cerveau est en mode minimale en
quelque sorte par défaut aucune
stimulation en particulier qui va
attirer en gros orienter le
fonctionnement cérébral et on sait qu'à
ce moment là il ya des zones du cerveau
qui sont toujours actives
systématiquement et qui sont des zones
souvent qui permette l'introspection et
qui ont un rapport avec le soin corporel
le soin corporel on n'arrive pas loin
quelque chose qui est si son soi c'est
son intégrité
quand on va être dans une situation de
douleur c'est qu'on a le ter l'intégrité
chez des gens douloureux on regarde
quand on met quelque chose d'intense
aimant plaisant par exemple une musique
sereine qui donne des frissons
et qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit que
l'écouté de cette musique a un effet
antalgique puissant au moment de l'
écoute évidemment et stimule le mode par
défaut donc facilite en quelque sorte
les l'introspection et renforcent ou
restaurants partie d'intégrité du soin
alors je vais aller plus loin ce mode
par défaut c'est aussi un mode qui est
activé lorsque vous avez l'esprit qui
vagabonde
vous avez quitté plusieurs fois là
depuis des vingt minutes
ce que j'ai dit et l'esprit à vagabonder
comme ça et plein de choses sont passées
qui vous n'êtes pas concentré ses salles
vagabondage de l'esprit d'accord ça vous
permet de supporter ce que vous entendez
par exemple est en fait ce vagabondage
de l'esprit c'est la base pour une part
mais pas que la base de la méditation
pleine conscience et la méditation
pleine conscience ça reste or l'individu
ça donne du bien-être et ça a un effet
antalgique puissant quand on la pratique
alors je vais vous montrer aussi que le
rejet social par des représentations ces
partages des représentations cérébrales
avec la douleur
donc c'est important vous avez des zones
qui sont activés autant lorsque dans un
situation de rejet social qu'en
situation de ressentis douloureux c'est
important et donc ça explique quoi que
le rejet social c'est un facteur majeur
de vulnérabilité de l'individu notamment
pour une douleur qui va ce chrono 6 et
donc on ne peut pas enlever le phénomène
social vous voyez que le cerveau est un
grand malin et qui l'utilisent en
quelque sorte des voix commune 1 pour
travailler enfin je terminerai par va y
arriver
oui on va y arriver il reste quelques
piles vous reste encore un peu de salive
également voilà en fait l'expérience
douloureuse c'est plusieurs dimensions a
cédé dimension affective kobe tive et
puis évidemment physiologique et il ya
un gars qui s'appelle mme elsa qui a
failli avoir le prix nobel mais qu'il
n'a pas eu qu'à qui était un type
remarquable dans le domaine de la
douleur
qui a dit la neuro matrice du soi c'est
à dire qu'est ce qui se passe dans le
cerveau pour dire que c'est moi c'est ni
plus ni moins quelque chose qui est
similaire à ce qui va me permettre
d'avoir le signal d'alarmé c'est à dire
la douleur et on a compris ça il ya très
peu de temps ouais parce qu'il n'existe
donc pas vous l'avez vu un centre
cérébrale de la douleur comme il existe
un centre de la vision primaire la
douleur c'est d'état de phénomènes de
l'eau physiologique imbriqués les uns
les autres avec des phénomènes cognitif
et ce qui nous permet de dire qu'en fait
kiss kiss qui ce que vous êtes vous et
votre enveloppe corporelle
c'est parce que vous en ressentez en
mettant des vêtements c'est pas parce
que vous vous touchez votre enveloppe
corporelle c'est votre intrigue tc votre
soi ainsi que vos organes et ça c'est
parce que les no 6 septembre encore une
fois tapissent votre peau c'est le seul
élément sensible qui est ubiquitaire est
partout donc vous êtes vous que parce
que vous avez des récepteurs sensibles
potentiellement à la douleur et que les
insensible congénitaux à la douleur du
fait d'une mutation sont des gens qui
vous mourir jeune dans des conditions
effroyables
on a besoin d'avoir mal dans son
expérience de vie pour être soit
d'accord alors je voulais simplement
vous rappeler ça il ya des gens
intelligents qui ont dit ça et en
particulier platon on va remettre le
dépasse que ça a l'air de d'être le des
deux démons voilà qui tombe bien
et en fait je voulais vous dire que
quand on a envie de souffrir
on peut comme cette jeune femme qui a
trois fois rien mais qui a l'air très
douillette et quand on le corse est
vraiment très durement si c'est plaisant
il ya plus aucun problème
[Applaudissements]